So the answer is, it really does nothing.
It'll make the computer do some work when we call sum,
but there's no good reason to ever call this procedure.
It doesn't have a return, so it doesn't produce any output,
and it doesn't actually modify the value of the first input in any way that's visible to the caller.
It does modify the value of a inside sum,
but the caller can't actually see that.
Let's see that in the Python interpreter so we make sure we understand what's going on here.
We'll define sum to take those 2 inputs and have the body that assigns to a,
the value a + b,
and we can try printing the result of calling sum.
Let's see if it can add 1 + 1.
When we run this, what we'll see is the result is actually None.
The reason the result is None is, while the sum procedure doesn't actually return anything,
so there's no value here.
Python uses the special value "None" to mean there's no value.
So that's not very useful.
We could pass in bigger numbers.
Whatever we pass in, will still get the result None because sum never returns anything.
To make sure it's clear what's going on here,
we're going to add some print statements to sum.
Printing things out is actually a perfectly good and perfectly useful way to test your code
to make sure that you understand what's going on.
It's always a good idea to add print statements.
Sometimes we call this debugging.
if the code has problems, adding print statements to see more what's going on
is a good way to figure that out.
Here I'm going to print that I've entered sum,
and I'll print the value of a, and I'll do the same thing again.
Now when we run it, we see that we "enter sum!"
When we enter sum, the value of a is 2.
That was the value passed in as the first parameter.
The value of b is 123. That was what we passed in at the second input.
When we print out the first print, a is 2.
We see a is 2. We do the arithmetic. That changes the value of a.
So now running the same print, it prints out the value of a as 125.
Then we return, we have the result. The result is None.
There's no output from sum, and that's what gets printed out.
So if we add a return statement to sum, now we have the original code that we had.
I've removed the print statements.
So we don't need to see those again.
We have this, and now we've added a return statement.
Now when we run this, we do get the value 125 because the output of sum
is what's returned here, which is the result of a at this point, which is 2 + 123.
The other thing I want to make clear without the return is that if we passed in variables for this,
it still does not change their value.
Let's say we had a variable--I'll even use a.
So I'm going to use the variable a. We'll initialize it to 2.
We'll have the variable b. We'll initialize that to 123.
We'll call sum. We still don't have the return, so it will return no value.
Let's see if the value of a has changed at the end, and it hasn't,
and the reason it hasn't is what gets passed in here--
even when we have a complex expression,
even when we use a name, or we have some calculation that produces the value--
what gets passed in is the value that that evaluates to.
So the fact that it was a name doesn't matter.
When we call sum, what's getting passed in as the value of a is the value that a refers to,
which is the number 2.
We don't actually modify what the variable is.
That's a totally separate variable.
Let me draw what that looks like to make it clear what's going on.
Here we have our code.
So that introduced a name "a,"
and it refers to the value 2,
and it introduced a name "b," and that refers to the value 123.
Both of those are numbers.
And we have our procedure that we defined like this.
It takes the 2 inputs.
It changes the the value of the input named a.
We're going to call sum, passing in a and b.
What happens when we call sum--we have these names here.
The names are our parameters.
We're going to have a name inside sum that's a.
That is going to refer to whatever value is passed in here.
So to know what the value is, we evaluate the name a. We get the value 2.
This a will refer to the value 2.
b will refer to the value passed in as b.
It's going to be the number 123.
And then when we run sum, we do the assignment.
That's going to produce the new number adding 2 + 123.
We get the value 125, and then we do the assignment.
The assignment changes what a refers to.
Now instead of referring to the number 2,
the a that corresponds to the parameter to the procedure sum, now refers to the number 125.
Note that the original value of a, the one that we named here, still refers to 2.
When we come back from the procedure, so once we get to here, we return.
We're back to running the code here.
All of the parameters that were visible inside the body of sum,
those are no longer visible.
They were there for that execution, but they're done.
We can't use those names anymore.
They were only visible during that execution of the procedure.
Now at this point, a refers to the number 2, just like it did before.